ich versuche wie ein schwamm zu sein
nichts helfen zu verstehen und
akzeptiert zu werden
noch bevor ich den fotoapparat in die
hand nehmen wenn ich das gefühl hatte
akzeptiert zu sein
kannte ich anfangen zu arbeiten wenn ich
eine situation sehe die mich berührt die
mir fast weh tut gibt es immer an der
moment des zögerns soll ich das foto
machen oder nicht einmal fotografiert
nützt es eine gute sache einmal gemacht
gibt es immer noch einen zustand der
selbstsucht sich sagt nein es ist
negativ es mag ein gutes bild sein aber
es schadet mehr als dass es nützt
ich bin auch schon in situationen hinein
geraten
eines tages stand ich plötzlich war ein
panzer der seine kann ohne direkt auf
mich nicht in nablus im norden palästina
ich wusste nicht dass eine
ausgangssperre herrschte ich hätte nach
hause gehen soll
ich machte ein paar schritte märkte dann
aber schnell das ist idiotisch war dass
ich dabei war einen blödsinn
eine falsche bewegung auf der seite des
panzers
es hätte gereicht und alles wäre zu ende
gewesen am anfang läuft ich immer dass
es in der dunkelkammer überraschungen
geben würde
aber im moment wo man den auslöser
drückt man weiß ist ein gutes bild
speichert man das ganze in der
dunkelkammer bestätigen sich die dinge
meist man täuscht sich sehen ich möchte
dass ein bild eines flüchtlings erzählt
was er erlebt hat
das flüchtlingslager zu gelangen das
irgendwo in seinem blick die hoffnung zu
sehen ist auf eine rückkehr zu etwas
akzeptabel